eleven was it give me your queen got it
five Fisher let's go
game on more Fisher random love it okay
what's unprotected this guy anything
else
no he's unprotected he's unprotected who
there might be something to be said for
a night be three to a five very quickly
that would be threatening a mate there
would be a million three one two three
three night moves me out of this
arrangement is possible that would be
seen of course I don't know if that's a
great idea to be doing that would it
really be inconvenient for my opponent
hmm it might be it might be huh night be
three
I might actually want to try that I'm
gonna go for it
identifying the weak point and going
after it just like in a regular chess
position right what's that weakest point
the f2 + f7 squares because only the
king defends it you'll know how the
other squares are defended by some other
piece in the regular chess position but
sometimes a Fischer and and we have
unprotected pieces from the initial
position so looking for Knight a5 and I
think that can be quite annoying if now
that is defended by b6 you'll note I
don't have to worry about their night
making use of b6 and coming to one of
these two and this rook is then
accessible to let's say a queen or a
LightSquared Bishop getting on this
diagonal so I think I'm already posing a
problem for my opponent in this with
this move maybe could they just be
ignoring it and say you know what I'm
gonna play a pawn in the center in meet
Knight a5 with Knight d6 mmm they're
doing 96 right away ok
the night is getting ready to play here
it's getting ready to play there let's
see
hmm
what do I do
hmm excuse me
let me wonder here I don't know I have
to really think about this one I'm
really trying to come up with a plan
that I would maybe doing like a longer
time control game I'm not just trying to
throw my pieces all out there
I really like devoting time to coming up
with the plan even if it's a bad plan
but at least I have some plan okay
I think I like this one dark Bishop I'll
stop the knight from playing to these to
this one in particular so I don't have
to worry about b2 and I'm preparing
efore in fact I'm gonna go with
something like e for f4 and Knight to f3
if allowed and with regard to my light
square bishop it's probably gonna be a 3
a 4 and then Bishop 2 a 2 in fact if a 4
I'll be then looking to play a 5 and
then maybe make use of a for later with
my rook one of these rip up and overs so
these are some of my ideas here
this arrangement okay and they're
stopping me from playing this making
getting ready for Knight f6 move well
let's do this I'm getting ready for this
I do weak in this square but my bishop
is around to watch over it could develop
that for this so we're both probably
going to be playing here in fact if the
knight eventually plays to this square
I'll be having to play this to watch
both III and my f4 pawn which would be
hit if there is an item is d5 square
this is still available should this
Knight leave I could be making use of
these two with a threat against b7
the bishop is ready to come out here
interesting idea
interesting idea okay they're gonna be
helping me develop though I'd have to be
extra cautious about this square now I
am ready to Castle kingside okay now
with this ooh
okay wait no I don't have to react yeah
I'm gonna do this and now this now there
is no castling queenside I can already
say that much to myself if there is no
Queen takes pawn either because my
knight is watching over the rook so now
I think I react I don't have a dark
square bishop so having some pawns on
dark squares to watch over those are
gonna be a good idea I'm doing two
things with this stopping the initial
trap and Bishop c2 is made available
Queen to f2 is probably is there going
to be a better move for my queen
probably not am I worried about doubled
pawns I'm not I would love to have this
going on so my rook could see now
decision time do I Castle kingside or do
I still mask that I think I actually
just play in the center no that's gonna
drop this pawn
let's not do that but maybe I can lift
to get that in somehow Queen trade night
here and then push ah let me go with
that Knight up and then upon push again
I'm not really worried about doubled
pawns at all my rook will have play
under two minutes for my opponent
hmm
okay I'm not really sure what I want to
do I might have thoughts of rook g1 and
then pawn push and stop that Knight move
I don't know it wasn't really even
threatened but okay I'm looking forward
to yeah I'm looking forward to still
getting in this move or this one okay
now I could get this move in I'm gonna
go for it now my queen is defending this
pawn so this move is available gaining
space in the center getting ready to
push forward even more and cramp my
opponent's position and
okay how to recapture bishop takes or
pawn takes go upon takes like my bishop
right here supporting my center but the
main thing is I like my rook having this
available
take care first I'm winning upon
actually winning upon
take with the queen
on the night I have a good Center and in
this resulting endgame what's the story
if Queens come off my opponent down to
30 here down to 30 here okay I'm just
going to exchange and get my king right
here this is a good spot and watch out
for that night and do not want to allow
to get to this square and I want to keep
one rook on the board actually so let's
do this improve my position I'm stopping
more Knight moves and I have a lot of
lateral movement if I pivot my rook on a
that Knight doesn't have any good moves
I'm in a position maybe push it around
maybe I should have considered this why
don't I do that instead that would that
would have been better preparing for it
now actually kicked the knight first and
then upon push
they are out of time here out of time
I'm gonna run with this if rip played
there I had Bishop f5 King has to take
now this end game I have a four to three
majority which by force could force a
right yeah by force it could get a
passed pawn
hmm if I could get my Bishop right here
it boxes out the night the night really
can't move and then it's a one King and
pawn endgame maybe I can make that
happen my opponent is okay so let's do
this and then take so this is a one King
and pawn endgame but they're they're out
of time at that point
all right good game interesting setup to
play with there huh that was a fun game
giving your clean fun game yeah from
this arrangement b7 and b2 are very
sensitive and we both kind of went into
it think right there on our first move
so my opponents already watching over it
over that b7 pun I don't know this right
here I don't know if it's a good idea to
allow me to take here and inconvenience
your rook it's also accessible later to
Queen f2 so I think you'd do better just
take and then even still retain the
option to queenside castle even though
it wouldn't be a good idea most likely
because I can get to a7 but at least
keep that option open don't let me have
you move your rook and well actually I
was wondering move one if there was
actually something like push your pawn
in the center and if Knight a5 then
Knight to d6 at least you allow your
Bishop to come out along this diagonal
first I think that's gonna be a little
bit better d5 and then Knight to d6 is
maybe a
way to be reacting to my potential
threat on b7 so that's my quick
suggestion and then again with regard to
not allowing me to force your rook to
move there I think I actually start to
be better here your knight since it's on
here there is no d6 to watch over the e5
square I'm able to make use of it and I
end up with a nice Center here so even
if there wasn't that drop of the pond I
think I have a 5 coming up a nice nice
group of pawns flexibility with my rook
I could castle in either direction I
could keep my king sitting so I think
the improvements are much earlier maybe
maybe just with the initial plan there's
going to be more a lot more than just
this plan that I'm suggesting but I
think this might be one to at least be
looking into first decent again d5 in
the 96 all right